So mal gucken, wer der erste im Chat heute ist.
Chatge.
Omega Chatge.
Der freut sich ja immer wieder am Start, der ist immer als erstes da.
Ist er auch nicht, ich frage mich echt, wie er das macht.
Mal kurz die Emotes ein bisschen verschieben.
Wer schenke ein Abo, um Platz 1 einzunehmen?
So so.
Der Chat.
Das ist echt blöd, dass man das nicht mehr im normalen Twitch-Chat einfach entfernen
kann.
Ich meine, ich habe FFZ installiert, da kann man das irgendwie ausblenden, aber es ist
trotzdem blöd.
Was ist da oben immer rumgammelt?
Leute, ich habe heute News gelesen und zwar, pass mal auf, ähm, richtige Keckweight-News.
Da habe ich mir gedacht, das ist ja fast die Baldur's Gate 3-Story in real life.
Wartet mal, ähm, Wurm im Gehirn.
Ja, wartet mal, ähm, News, ja, aber in Australien, Alter, in Australien bringt dich alles um.
Guckt euch das an.
Also die Australier, ich weiß nicht, da bringt dich alles um.
Schlangen, Frösche, Spinnen, Kängurus, Krokodile, alles, in Australien bringt dich einfach alles
um.
Und neuerdings gibt es in Australien auch Würmer im Gehirn.
Müsst ihr euch mal vorstellen, da haben sie irgendeine Frau, die hatte erst Bauchschmerzen,
Atemprobleme und irgendwann Vergesslichkeit und dann haben sie ihr so ein Bild vom Innenleben,
vom Schädel gemacht und haben festgestellt, dass sich da drin was bewegt, weil die Änderung
von einem Bild zum anderen, ich weiß nicht, ob es da, nee, Tagschauter, kein Bild, war
zu groß und dann haben sie irgendwann festgestellt, dass die einen, ich glaube, 8 oder 10 Zentimeter
großen Wurm im Kopf hatte, Alter, der dann irgendwie im Gehirn rumgefressen hat und so,
so richtig abartig.
Ist fast ein bisschen wie die Baldur's Gate 3-Story, nur, dass sie wahrscheinlich nicht
zu irgendeinem Mindflayer mutiert.
Ja, ja, ja, die haben den rausoperiert.
Die haben den Kopf da aufgemacht und den Wurm rausgeholt und dass das besonders eklig ist,
merkt man daran, dass die Ärztin, die sie operiert hat, gesagt hat, dass sie das eklig
fand und ihr könnt davon ausgehen, wenn Chirurgen was eklig finden, dann muss das wirklich eklig
sein.
Also, wenn es euch gefallen hat, ich bin täglich am BG3 spielen, also wir haben noch nicht
viel weiter gespielt als im Stream, wir können ruhig demnächst noch weiter bashen,
Alter.
Ich meine, meine Roleplaying-Skills halten sich in Grenzen, aber muss trotzdem gelootet
und gebashed werden, so, ja, wie immer.
Ja, und, also es ist echt krass in Australien.
So, und im Nachhinein kam dann raus, wie gesagt, ich will euch jetzt nicht den Artikel vorlesen,
das sage ich bloß kurz jetzt, der steht da aber sicherlich auch bei der Tagesschau
irgendwie, ne?
Die hatte den, glaube ich, 16 Monate oder so im Körper, den Wurm, und die hatte erst
Magenprobleme, Bauchschmerzen, Verdauungsprobleme, Atemprobleme und irgendwann hat sie Konzentrationsprobleme
und Gedächtnisverlust und sowas gehabt und das kam daher, je nachdem, wo der Wurm gerade
war, die hatte ihn wahrscheinlich zu sich genommen mit irgendwelchem selbstgeerntetem
Grünzeug aus dem Wald oder aus dem Busch irgendwie in Australien, dann war der zuerst
im Magen, so, und dann hat der da im Magen rumgewurmt und dann hatte sie erst, da hatte
sie halt, da hatte sie halt Magenprobleme und Verdauungsprobleme, dann ist der langsam
hochgewandert, so durch die Lunge, Alter, da hat sie Atemprobleme gehabt, und irgendwann
hoch bis ins Hirn und dann hat sie Vergesslichkeit, da wurde sie vergesslich und hatte Konzentrationsprobleme
und dann haben sie erst gemerkt, da ist ein Wurm im Hirn, also echt krasse Story, normalerweise
lese ich sowas gar nicht, aber das war echt, gerade weil ich gerade Baldur's Gate 3 spiele,
das ist echt heftig, ja, naja, aber wie gesagt, in Australien bringt dich eh alles um, 2 Meter
nebenan Weg gelaufen, also auf dem Weg ist auch egal, die haben ja da alles, die haben
Schildkröten oder so, die dir Finger abbeißen können, eben alles, also in Australien bringt
dich echt alles um, ja, hat er ja wohl, hat er ja wohl, der hat ja nicht einfach nur abgechillt
da oben, wird ja auch gesagt, dass ein Großteil der Katzenbesitzer einen Parasit im Körper
haben, naja, also, ja, bestimmt hast du keinen 10 oder 8 cm langen, weiß gar nicht wie lang
der jetzt wirklich war, irgendwie 8 oder 10 cm im Kopf, ja, also was das angeht, die haben,
ja, Südamerika ist auch so, aber Australien ist, glaube ich, das krasseste, die haben alles,
giftige Schlangen, Frösche, Krokodile, Spinnen, egal, es bringt dich, bringt dich alles um,
ich habe, ich habe letztens in irgendeinem Beitrag gelesen, dass, also in Australien haben
die auch total viele solcher, so, wie heißt denn das, so Notfallstationen für Schlangenbisse und
sowas, so und ich habe letztens in irgendeinem Artikel gelesen, dass die australischen, übelst
random Thema, ich weiß, ok, aber, dass die australischen Ureinwohner, wenn sie von einer
Schlange gebissen wurden, da konnten die halt noch nicht in irgendeine Notfallaufnahme oder
so fahren, die haben ihr Bein genommen und die haben ein Loch gebuddelt in die Erde und haben
hier ihr Bein in das Loch gesteckt und ganz fest mit Erde zugemacht, bis das wieder gut war, so
und das sollte wohl dazu dienen, also, don't try this at home, das habe ich irgendwo gelesen,
ja, keine Ahnung, ob das stimmt und keine Ahnung, ob das wirklich sinnvoll ist, ja,
ich erzähle es jetzt bloß trotzdem, zumindest, die haben ja ihr Bein in ein Loch gesteckt,
in der Erde, haben das ganz fest mit Erde zugebuddelt, da, wo sie mit, von der Schlange
gebissen wurden, das hat erstens dazu geführt, dass sich das Gift nicht so, nicht so sehr im
Körper verbreitet hat und, dass das Bein nicht mehr so gut durch, durchblutet wurde und deswegen
das Gift irgendwie nicht so effektiv war, ganz abgedrehtes Zeug, ja, tja, aber in Australien
ist halt echt, ist halt echt alles, alles vorbei, wenn dich da irgendwas beißt, Instant, Instant
Dead, ja, das kann ja wahrscheinlich ein bisschen dauern, manche, also, ich habe keine Ahnung,
ob, wie gesagt, ob das stimmt, aber das kann ja durchaus sein, das braucht ja alles auch ein
bisschen und es hält dafür auch manchmal drei Tage oder länger, bis das, bis das alles irgendwie
überwunden ist und dann hatten die halt drei Tage ihr, ihr, ihr Bein in irgendeinem Erdloch stecken.
Wo wir übrigens gerade bei Beinen in irgendeinem Erdloch stecken sind, hat es nicht so wirklich
was mit Beinen und Erdlöchern zu tun? Wenn jetzt einer zum ersten Mal in den Stream ist,
der denkt sich auch, Keck Wade, was, was labert er? Zumindest eine, eine Sache,
ich habe heute, ich bin normalerweise jetzt ja die letzten, die letzten Tage immer Rennen gegangen,
jeden zweiten Tag, das Längste, was ich bisher gelaufen habe, war, weil tatsächlich ja immer mal
wieder welche Fragen, ich erzähle euch das, ich habe eine neue, einen, einen neuen Rekord, was
Reichweite angeht und zwar, lass mich mal kurz gucken, Kalender, ich bin 7,74 Kilometer gerannt,
in einer Stunde, eine Minute und 15 Sekunden, allerdings bin ich diesmal absichtlich nicht so
schnell gerannt, wie ich konnte, 148 Puls im Durchschnitt und 7 Minuten 55 pro Kilometer
und warum ich euch das erzähle, ist folgendes, das war vor, das war am 28, also das war am 28
um 9 Uhr, also sprich, das ist jetzt, sagen wir mal zweieinhalb Tage her, was ist da die Pace? Ja,
7 Minuten 55 pro Kilometer oder willst du, oder willst du die Geschwindigkeit wissen? Die
Geschwindigkeit ist 7,6 kmh, 7,6 kmh und 7 Minuten 55 pro Kilometer im Durchschnitt, zumindest, ja,
ja, mittlerweile kann ich tatsächlich rennen, man glaubt es gar nicht, so und zumindest,
zumindest, warum ich das, 10 Kilometer 55 Minuten, das ist ziemlich gut, das ist ziemlich gut, unter
60 Minuten 10 Kilometer, ist ziemlich gut, zumindest, warum ich, warum ich das erzähle, ist, normalerweise
habe ich mir, renne ich ja jeden zweiten Tag, aber ich bin heute nicht, ich bin heute nicht gerannt,
weil, ich, mir hat nach diesen 7,7, runden wir es mal auf, nach diesen 7,8 Kilometern, hat mir echt das
links und rechts, so ein bisschen das Knie weh getan, gerade beim Treppe runterlaufen, die Wade,
alter, ich sag euch, und am schlimmsten war mein Schienbein, alter, das Schienbein hat weh getan,
also, dann habe ich mir gedacht, weißt du was, ich mache mal lieber einen Tag länger Pause, bevor
ich, bevor ich weiterrenne, morgen früh werde ich wieder meine Runde rennen, so diese Standard 6
Kilometer Runde, aber es ist wirklich ein Unterschied, hätte ich gar nicht gedacht,
machen wir das mal mit dem Wurm weg, es ist wirklich ein Unterschied, ob du 7,8 oder 6
Kilometer rennst, also 6 Kilometer packe ich mittlerweile easy und auch ohne, dass mir großartig
was wehtut danach, ich meine, vielleicht ein bisschen kaputt, den restlichen Tag über, so
merkt man beim Treppe runterlaufen und hochlaufen, aber ansonsten kein Problem, aber die 7,7 waren
schon, da hatten wir wirklich mehr, also was mir ein bisschen Sorgen gemacht hat, ist, dass mir mein
Schienbein wehtut, weil ich meine, ich meine, am Schienbein hast du ja keine großartigen Muskeln
oder so und wenn ich so aufs Schienbein, jetzt geht es wieder, jetzt merke ich nichts mehr,
aber wenn ich aufs Schienbein drauf gedrückt habe, gestern noch, an manchen Stellen hat es
wirklich gezogen, so wie wenn man einen blauen Fleck hätte, ihr kennt doch bestimmt, jeder kennt
doch das Gefühl, wenn man einen blauen Fleck hat und da aus Versehen ein bisschen drauf drückt,
so hat sich das bei mir am Schienbein angefühlt, da habe ich mir gedacht, okay, das ist keine allzu
gute Sache, dass dir dein Schienbein wehtut nach dem Rennen, mach mal lieber einen Tag länger Pause
und das hat auch geholfen, heute ist es schon wieder viel besser, ich bin vorher plus ungefähr
eineinhalb Stunden langsam gelaufen, also nicht gejoggt, also wirklich langsam, langsam gelaufen,
bisschen hier durch den Wald und das bisschen Bewegung am Tag muss ja sein. Du hast, du hast
gegoogelt, du hast, du hast gegoogelt, ich habe auch gegoogelt, das nennt man nicht so, das nennt
man nur so, wenn es, wenn die Knochenhaut entzündet ist und dann hast du andere Schmerzen,
andere Probleme, das merkst du bei Belastung auch. Nee, nee, ich, das ist einfach überlastet und
überanstrengend. Natürlich muss man gucken, dass es nicht noch schlimmer wird, ja, das ist klar.
SgtSilva schreibt, war heute bei einem Unternehmen in der zweiten Runde. Gwent Essence,
der Geschäftsführer, wollte mein Gesicht sehen und meine Stimme hören. Ja gut, das kann ich
auch verstehen, also bei einem, ganz ehrlich, bei einem, bei einem Bewerbungskandidat und so,
irgendwann würde ich den auch mal sehen wollen, ja, das kann ich verstehen. Termin ging sieben
Minuten, Moment, Termin ging sieben Minuten, man hat immer noch keine Ansage gemacht, was ich bei
der Stelle verdienen werde und Co, aber man meldet sich nächste Woche. Hatte ich ein erstes mal ein
Unternehmen bei mir im Stadtteil, 72,5k wollen sie nicht zahlen, weil ich dann mehr als der
IT-Leiter verdienen würde. Ich weiß nicht, welche Branche und ich weiß nicht, welche Region, aber
für einen Leiter IT erscheinen mir 72k dann doch ein bisschen wenig. Man darf ja nicht vergessen,
das ist eine Position, die gibt es einmalig pro Unternehmen, also das ist, das ist, das ist ja
quasi die, die, die höchste Stufe, die man im Karriere-Crime erreichen kann und dafür lohnt
sich da auch jetzt nicht wirklich den krassen Karriere-Crime hinzulegen. Also Strives, 5 Minuten
40 pro Kilometer ist ziemlich gut, ja und, ich meine, wenn das, jetzt musst du jetzt mal erzählen, also wenn
der Termin sieben Minuten ging, ihr habt euch ja bestimmt nicht sieben Minuten einfach nur angeguckt,
was wollte der so wissen? Bist du eigentlich Wimchamp? Ich bin Wimchamp, ja, allerdings ich bin, zur
Zeit bin ich eine Mischung aus Wimchamp, VS Code Champ und JetBrains Champ, hauptsächlich
VS Code Champ, allerdings auf CLI und über SSH selbstverständlich immer Wimchamp. VS Code Wimplugin
installieren? Ne, mag ich nicht. Das ist, das ist tatsächlich sehr merkwürdig, ne, ihr kennt mich ja, ich
benutze es ganz gerne, wenn es kommen, wenn es, wenn es um Kommandozeilen-Editing geht. Kommandozeilen-Editing,
auch geiler Satz, ihr wisst, was ich meine, wenn es ums Bearbeiten von Textfiles auf der Kommandozeile geht,
dann wisst ihr, ich bin eigentlich hauptsächlich ja Wim-User, aber, was ich eigentlich ganz lustig finde, ja,
also hier Kommandozeile immer automatisch, Wim-Editieren, alles gut, aber wenn ich Visual Studio Code benutze,
da habe ich kein Wim-Plugin. Ich mag das nicht, ich kann, ich kann euch nicht genau erklären,
woran das liegt, ich weiß halt nur, also mein Gedanke dahinter ist, Wim VS Code Plugins, ne, ich mag das
nicht, ich mag das nicht, weil irgendwie habe ich so mental schalte ich um zwischen Editor und Terminal
und wenn ich in meinem Hirn im Terminal-Modus bin, dann habe ich auch gar kein Problem mit Wim-Shortcuts
und irgendwie Wim-Abkürzungen, wenn ich in Visual Studio Code bin, dann will ich Maus klicken können
und Multi-Cursor und so ein G'schiss machen können. Ups, was habe ich jetzt? Fuck. Ich weiß nicht, ich mag kein Wim-Plugin,
ich habe auch in Rider kein Wim-Plugin. Ich habe eigentlich nirgendswo ein Wim-Plugin, außer in Wim.
Ich hatte, wobei das stimmt nicht, in Emacs, so in Zeiten, als ich noch Emacs verwendet habe, da hatte ich Evil-Mode.
Hat das schon mal jemand verwendet von euch? Oh, hier gibt's Updates. Und schon mal Evil-Mode benutzt von euch
in Emacs. Das ist quasi eine Wim-Emulation für Emacs. Böse Zungen behaupten, das ist endlich ein gescheiter Editor für Emacs.
Das heißt Evil-Mode, weil Wim- und Emacs-User sich ja immer ein bisschen gegenseitig bashen müssen.
Also ich glaube, dass alles hundertprozentig wieder weg wäre, müsste ich wahrscheinlich mal so drei, vier Tage Pause machen,
aber nee, das passt schon. Ich habe mir jetzt ja neue Schuhe gekauft, habe ich euch ja gezeigt.
Ich habe mir jetzt, ähm, ich habe mir jetzt ja hier ein Pack, was ist ein Pack? Ein Paar, kein Pack, Alter.
Ah, Flashback, Alter, ich muss die Seite mal aufmachen in Chrome. Ich habe mir hier so ein Pack gekauft in Exact,
die, warte mal, ich bring das, nee, das hier, in dieser Farbkombination, weil die haben halt super, super nice Federungen.
Und das ist für Leute wie mich, die jetzt nicht so leicht sind und nicht so dünn sind, ist das sehr praktisch.
Und ich muss sagen, damit ist viel, ohne Scheiß, viel, extrem viel angenehmer zu laufen, als mit den normalen Turnschuhen.
Das ist RGB, das macht es nochmal extra schneller. Die Waage, die Waage hat sich bis jetzt nicht verändert.
Ist immer noch, ist immer noch morgens, ja es schwankt, es schwankt zwischen, sag ich mal, 91 und 94, je nachdem.
Also wenn ich mich nicht bewegt habe den Tag, mega viel gefressen habe und mich mit Hose und allem auf die Waage stelle,
dann ist es 94 und wenn ich mich morgens wiege, dann ist es meistens 92,5 und wenn ich mich wiege,
nachdem ich eine Runde gerannt bin vormittags, dann ist es meist 91,5 oder so.
Aber es ist, es ist ja, es ist nicht mehr runtergegangen, es ist nicht mehr runtergegangen, seit ich angefangen habe zu rennen.
Bei welcher Größe? 1,74.
Ähm, und, also es ist nicht, es ist nicht weiter runtergegangen, seit ich angefangen habe zu rennen.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, woran das liegt, ich könnte mir vorstellen, das dauert einfach ein bisschen.
Ich meine, ich mache ja, ich mache ja eh meine normale Runde am Tag, meine 1,5 Stunden Wanderrunde und dann halt noch 45 bis 60 Minuten Rennen.
Und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das, ich hatte letztens, zumindest ich habe hier so eine Fitness-Tracker-Uhr,
ich habe letztens, sagt meine Fitness-Tracker-Uhr ja, mit meiner 1,5 Runde morgens und mit meiner 50 Minuten Rennrunde abends,
habe ich über 1000 Kalorien angeblich verbrannt.
Also ich habe quasi ein Drittel, fast ein bisschen mehr als ein Drittel von meinem Tagesbedarf weggerannt.
Also ich könnte mir auch vorstellen, dass das erstens so ein bisschen dauert, bis man davon abnimmt
und wahrscheinlich werde ich auch erstmal noch ein paar Muskeln jetzt kriegen, dadurch, dass ich damit angefangen habe
und wahrscheinlich am Anfang ein bisschen Verbranntes in Muskelmasse dazukriegen.
Naja, was heißt es nicht zum Abnehmen?
Unterm Strich musst du mehr verbrauchen, als du reinschiebst.
Und wenn du insgesamt am Tag durch Bewegung 1000 Kalorien mehr verbrauchst, dann hast du die am Ende des Tages weniger.
Du suchst nach einem 1,74 Meter großen Dude mit bunten Schuhen, korrekt.
Allerdings nur, wenn ich am Laufen bin.
Wenn ich in der Stadt bin oder so, dann habe ich nicht die Schuhe an.
Zumindest, den finde ich echt nice.
Also es fühlt sich so viel angenehmer an, damit zu laufen, als mit den normalen Turnschuhen.
Gerade weil ich dann auch ein bisschen schwerer bin und da knallt halt echt einiges so auf Knie und Schienbein und so drauf
und das ein bisschen abfedert.
Und das federt richtig, Leute.
Also, wenn ihr das noch nicht gesehen habt, ich habe auch erst mal gedacht, darauf kann man doch nicht laufen.
Ihr müsst euch das mal bei YouTube angucken.
Wie das, warte mal, wenn da einer drin läuft, wie das, das sieht aus wie...
Weiß ich nicht, ob der zeigt, wie das läuft.
Das sieht aus, ja hier zeigt das drauf schon, das sieht aus wie...
Ja, stell dich mal drauf, Kollege.
Ähm, man sieht es jetzt hier nicht.
Ähm, das sieht aus, hier, hier, guck mal.
Das, das, das, das sieht, guck mal, das sieht aus, seht ihr das?
Das, ja man erkennt es, ja doch, hier erkennt man es.
Das sieht aus, als würde man auf einem Kissen laufen, seht ihr das?
Das ist wie, als hätte einer so ein Kissen drunter gepackt.
Aber, es ist extrem, extrem angenehm, da drin zu laufen, wirklich extrem angenehm.
Hätte ich nicht gedacht, ich dachte am Anfang so, ja okay, Dämpfung und so, alles ganz nice, aber halt sehr wobbel, wobbel alles.
Und ja ist es, aber es ist nicht so schlimm, wie ich gedacht habe, dafür ist es halt viel angenehmer.
Dein linker Arm ist überlastet.
Das ist vielleicht auch mal ein Tag Pause, man.
Das ist, das ist das Arsch, Arsch unter den, unter den Schuhen, naja.
Das ist aber wirklich ziemlich zackig.
Wir sind bestimmt nicht der Erste, der das hier schreibt, aber Freitag geht's los.
Freitag geht's los. Ja, Chatky, bei wem geht's noch Freitags los?
1.9. Das ist beliebter Startpunkt für Ausbildung und neue Jobs.
Hauptsächlich für Ausbildung.
Bei manchen fängt's glaube ich auch schon im August an, bei manchen auch erst im Oktober.
Bei wem geht's noch los, oder ist iChunkerNotChunk der Einzige?
Bei der besten.
Bei dir geht's los in einem Startup.
Starfield? Nein.
Ich glaube, ich glaube es geht um, um PhysiStart oder sowas.
Oder? Bin ich mir gar nicht sicher, ich vermute es jetzt einfach mal.
Du bist, du bist BrainLagChamp.
Das muss ich auch sagen, hier Leute, das hätte ich, das hätte ich nicht gedacht, aber
ich habe wirklich das Gefühl, mein Hirn ist nicht mehr so krass Boomer, seit ich angefangen habe zu rennen.
Mir kommt das vor, als kann ich mich besser, besser konzentrieren.
Aber gut, mein halt Durchblutung und alles, ja.
Dafür, was anderes, dafür, ich bin jetzt ziemlich genau fünf Monate bei der neuen, beim neuen Job
und ich war eigentlich bis jetzt durchgehend motiviert.
Aber früher oder später musste das, musste das ja auch mal kommen.
Jetzt so in den letzten ein, zwei Tagen habe ich es gemerkt, so meine Hyper-Motivation so zum Einstieg hat jetzt schon wieder ein bisschen nachgelassen.
Ich mache zum Glück mittlerweile den größten Teil des Tages, kann ich Zeug machen, worauf ich Bock habe.
Aber so dieses super, ich muss mich überall einbringen, ich muss überall was zu sagen.
Ich will einen guten Eindruck machen, ich will zeigen, dass ich Ahnung habe und so.
Es verfliegt langsam, es verfliegt langsam.
Es verfliegt langsam.
Ich habe jetzt, ich bin zum Beispiel, bin ich jetzt schon wieder in meinem normalen Meeting-Modus angekommen.
Mein normaler Meeting-Modus ist, wenn keiner was sagt zu mir, sage ich auch nichts.
Das ist mein normaler Meeting-Modus, den habe ich seit Jahren schon.
Und ich mache lieber in der Zwischenzeit irgendwas anderes, zum Beispiel irgendwas weiter skripten, irgendwas weiter programmieren, irgendwas weiter ausprobieren.
Und wenn mich halt einer was fragt in Meetings, dann sage ich das.
Bei Dailies überlege ich mir vorher kurz was und sage dann halt ein paar Punkte, aber meistens sage ich, ja gut, sonst gibt es auch nichts Interessantes mehr.
Ich habe so diesen, diesen, diesen, ja, ich, diesen, diesen, wie nennt man das denn, diesen Bestätigungstrang ist schon wieder weg nach fünf Monaten.
Ich glaube, ich glaube, das hält jedes Mal kürzer.
Als ich damals die Ausbildung angefangen habe, Leute, ich hatte das ja gefühlt irgendwie eineinhalb Jahre oder so, wo ich da auf 180 war und immer überall was mitbekommen wollte und sagen wollte und zeigen wollte, dass ich auch jetzt was gelernt habe und so.
Ich glaube, ich glaube, mittlerweile ist es einfach so, wenn man selbst ein bisschen realisiert hat, dass man nicht ganz Kacke ist in seinem Bereich, ja, dann, dann lässt so dieser Geltungsdrang einfach auch relativ schnell nach.
Weil man, man muss sich halt nicht unbedingt permanent den ganzen Tag selbst bestätigen, ja.
Am Anfang, ja, so die ersten zwei, drei Monate, sicherlich muss man halt auch mal ein bisschen unter Beweis stellen, dass man schon einen Plan hat.
Das ist auch bestimmt nicht verkehrt, am Anfang das mal zu zeigen.
Aber mittlerweile, ich bin, ich habe es gemerkt, ich habe es heute Morgen richtig gemerkt.
Ich habe mir gedacht, oh ne, schon wieder gemiete heute den ganzen Tag und ach, weißt du was, setz dich in die Meetings, hörst ein bisschen zu nebenbei und bastelst an deinem Kram weiter.
Und wenn mich keiner fragt, sage ich nix.
Ja Mann, machst du den, machst du dann den, den Bouldering Kreisel Grind.
Ich habe mal ein paar Videos geguckt von, von, von irgendeinem Kerl auf, auf YouTube, der ist, das war, das war echt auch super, super krass als ich das gesehen habe.
Der ist an irgendeinem Felsen, oh frag mich nicht, Teneriffa oder Lanzarote oder so.
Ist der, der ist an so einer Felswand lang geklettert in so eine Höhle rein.
Höhle rein und da war nix an dieser Felswand, nix. Das ist so, da hätte ich mich nicht mal, wenn es um Leben und Tod geht, irgendwie dran festhalten können für ein paar Sekunden. Da war nichts, die Felswand sah für mich einfach glatt aus und der Typ ist da lang geklettert und dann ist der irgendwie so kopfüber in diese Höhle reingeklettert. Ich meinte, Alter, was geht mir den Läuten ab? Vor allem, wie hält der sich da fest und dann habe ich von dem gleichen Kerl mal irgendwann so ein Video gesehen in so einem
Wie nennt man das in so einem Kletterstudio? Wie heißt das in so einem Trainingskletterraum? Ey, Alter, der hat sich an Vorsprüngen festgehalten mit seinen Fingern. Die hätte ich nicht mal als Vorsprünge erkannt.
Ne, den meine ich nicht, aber von dem habe ich auch schon irgendein Bergklettervideo geguckt. Alter, was zum Teufel ist mit dem los?
Ne, du, danke für den Sub. Ähm, was war die Frage? Wo es die Hintergründe gibt? Ja, die Hintergründe gibt es hier. Die hat der Rackman gebastelt. Ja, Credits. Hier gibt es die Hintergründe. Guck, auf ShitHub.
Du hast für jeden Tag, äh, für jede Tageszeit hast du was passendes dabei. Ja, genau, Noah Lost Pancakes, das war der. Der Name ist mir im Kopf geblieben, ja.
Normalerweise bin ich nicht so ein Sportvideosgucker, aber von dem habe ich mal zwei, drei geguckt. Da habe ich auch echt gedacht, das ist nicht normal, woran der Kerl sich festhält.
Falls du Linux benutzt, wer hat das gefragt? Turtonk? Achso, direkt da oben drüber war die Frage. Falls du Linux benutzt, kannst du auch eins von diesen beiden Skripts verwenden, um dir automatisch den Background alle 15 Minuten umzusetzen.
In der Variante von Max ist das sogar mit Wetter-RP und anhand der Sonnenuntergangszeit setzt er dann sogar den richtigen Background. Aber du kannst doch einfach Background... Was hat Ryder am Start hier? Was ist da los?
Wollte ich nicht upgraden gerade? Habe ich gesagt, ich soll upgraden? Und jetzt hier upgraden? Nothing to do. Verdächtig. Cannot update?
Ist meine Disk voll? Temp ist... What the fuck? Was ist das? Was liegt denn hier alles für ein Schrott rum in Temp? Ich bin ein wenig verwirrt. Ich glaube, ich reboote mal.
Jetzt nach Kernel Update und sowas. Keine Ahnung, was das gerade für Schmerzen... Temp ist voll. Aber sollte... Ja gut, der anzippt wahrscheinlich in Temp. War jetzt eigentlich nicht mein Plan, aber schauen wir mal, was der für Schmerzen hat.
Okay, WhitePepoHappyBackground wurde jetzt gesetzt zu PepoSleepTime. Use 1%. Okay, alles wieder gut. Lass uns mal schauen. Moment, kann das sein, dass mein Temp zu klein ist, dass ich alle Jetbrain-Tools auf einmal updaten kann?
Vor allem, warum habe ich bitteschön IntelliJ installiert? Ich mache doch gar kein Ja-Fahrzeug. Lass mal kurz zugucken hier. WatchDF-H. Ja, ja. Alter, der lädt nach Temp runter. Ist der total bescheuert? Was ist das für Pepega-Shit, Alter? Was ist das für Pepega-Shit? Kann er das nicht in Home machen? Da hat er 133 Gig frei.
Okay, wisst ihr was? Wir brauchen IntelliJ nicht. Uninstall. Oh, easy. Oh, thanks. Jetzt update. Das hatte ich aber auch noch nicht. Moment, guckt mal, der gibt das gar nicht wieder frei. Das ist ja richtig krasses Pepega-Zeug. Gibt er das wieder frei, wenn ich das hier... Warum gibt er es dann beim Rebooten frei? Löscht er neuerdings Temp beim Rebooten? Das ist aber auch nicht normal.
Dankeschön für den Sub. So, jetzt probieren wir das nochmal. Vielleicht hätte ich es beenden sollen. Ja, jetzt ist es wieder frei. So, okay. Coolbox. Gucken, ob das jetzt geht. Also, ich gehe mal davon aus, wenn man es einzeln updatet, wird es ohne Probleme funktionieren.
Das ist doch aber auch neu, dass es nach TMP geht, oder? Okay. Alles klar. Das benutzt er wirklich nur für den Download. Guck mal, das braucht er nur für den Download. Der Rest ist kein Ding. Funktioniert. Easy.
Das ist auch Schrott, oder? Ah, gut. Na gut. So, gut, haben wir geupdatet. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, warum ich überhaupt gestartet und geupdatet habe, aber okay. IntelliJ war es wieder. Ja, Java-Kram, wie immer.
Wieso sollte man sich WIM auch in VS Code antun? Naja, wenn man ein WIM-Fan ist und die WIM-Shortcuts und die WIM... Das sind ja keine Shortcuts in WIM. Wie kann man das nennen? Diese WIM-Language zum Texteditieren gerne benutzt. Warum nicht?
Also, ich kenne einige, die das machen. Nicht nur in VS Code. Motions, genau. Sondern auch in allen möglichen anderen IDEs. Es gibt ja für fast alle WIM-Plugins. Wobei, so richtig gut ist es eigentlich nur in WIM. Oder meinetwegen in Emacs, falls irgendjemand so verrückt noch ist.
Aber ich mag das nicht. Ich mag es in WIM selber, aber ich mag es nicht in anderen Editors. Ich zeige euch übrigens mal was. Ist tempfs nicht im RAM? Moment, ist es tempfs? Sekunde, doch, dann ist es im... Nee, Quatsch. Moment, Moment, Moment. Ich muss mal gucken.
tempfs schon, aber temp nicht unbedingt. Moment, ist es im RAM? Moment, habe ich das im RAM? Ich glaube, das ist im RAM. Das ist gar nicht auf meiner Disk. Ach, deswegen ist es nur... Ist das... RAM-Disk. Ach so, deswegen habe ich auch nur 12 GB Temp, weil das in RAM geht. Okay.
Wie viel habe ich denn an RAM drinnen? Ja, 24 GB, ja, deswegen erklärt. Aber das sollte trotzdem nicht sein, was er so viel da braucht. Ich wollte euch noch den 5-Hit-Win-Hack zeigen. Passt mal auf. Config, Western, Lua. So, jetzt machen wir hier irgendwas auf.
So, Chat, mal angenommen, ich möchte jetzt diesen String hier austauschen. Primary Selection. Von der Stelle hier. Was ist die beste Variante, das zu machen? Wer ist der WIM-5-Header hier? Ja, das ist gut. CI, ja. Okay, ich sehe, Chat, ihr kennt das schon alle. Also, einige kennt's, ja.
Du kannst CI, CI, Change Inner und dann Quotes und dann springt das zum nächsten Zeichen und dazwischen läuft das dann. Das geht auch mit Wörtern hier. CIW zum Beispiel, wobei man das mit CW in dem Fall einfacher haben kann.
Ja, also das kann man sich merken, das ist tatsächlich eines der nützlichsten WIM-Dinger, weil man will ja oftmals Variablen neu anlegen, ja. Das funktioniert übrigens mit ganz viel. Das funktioniert auch mit Single Quotes, Change Inner. Ja, wenn ich jetzt die Tasse...
Geht das? Das geht auch mit Klammern. Das geht eigentlich mit fast allem. Ja, ja, das geht auch. Wobei, ich glaube nicht, dass der Multiline fähig ist. Oh, guck mal, der kann sogar Multiline. Habt ihr das gesehen? Change Inner, Klammern, Multiline-5-Head.
Ja, Ergebnis gibt es noch mehr, aber das wollte ich euch an der Stelle bloß mal zeigen, weil ich das immer ganz, ganz praktisch finde. Okay. Naja, das war jetzt nicht so viel, was wir dich gefragt haben. Ja, und was hattest du für einen Eindruck von denen?
Ich meine, in der heutigen Zeit ist es ja so, dass es nicht unbedingt primär nur darauf ankommt, dass die wollen, sondern dass du auch willst. Also, ich hatte heute einen Termin mit meinem Chef und er hat gemeint, sie wollen mich auch nach der Probezeit behalten.
Aber das, wenn nicht, wäre vorher ja schon klar gewesen. Das hat er, glaube ich, nur so als Gag eingestreut. Übrigens, ach Max, wir wollen dich auch nach der Probezeit behalten. Weil es ist ja, ich meine, in einem Monat ist meine Probezeit rum. Ja, und so wie es aussieht, die Kollegen auch.
Wie setzt du Wim auf für Softwareentwicklung? Gar nicht. Ich entwickle in Wim nichts Großartiges. Ich editiere nur auf der Kommandozeile und über SSH überschaubare Sachen. Konfigs oder irgendwelche Skripts oder wenn mal was angepasst werden muss nachträglich, was schon auf dem Server liegt oder so. Ich mache keine großen Projekte mit Wim. Da drehe ich durch bei.
Ich habe das früher gemacht. Ich hatte früher mal Wim aufgemotzt wie sonst was. Ja, C-Sharp in Wim willst du nicht machen. Wobei das mit Language, Server und sowas alles irgendwo möglich ist. Aber es ist immer noch Kacke, weil einiges von diesem ganzen C-Sharp Tooling ist halt nicht, ich will nicht sagen nicht Open Source, das ist es nicht, aber nicht, wahrscheinlich auch nicht Open Source, aber auf jeden Fall nicht gut integrierbar.
Das siehst du ja bei JetPrintsRider, die haben ja viele selbstgebaut und benutzen gar nicht das Microsoft Zeug. Ja, und dementsprechend ist C-Sharp in Visual Studio Code witzigerweise auch totaler Müll.
Nee, die Schuhe kosten nicht 200 Euro. Das habe ich letztens schon gezeigt, wenn man bei Amazon guckt. Hier, da hattest du ja letztens schon gesagt, guck mal. Bei Amazon kosten die 135 Euro oder guck mal hier 124 Euro. Zwischen 124 und 140, also warum auch immer die 200 kosten auf der offiziellen Seite, keine Ahnung.
Das glaube ich nicht, da ist man ein bisschen hin. Wobei du bist ne Ecke größer, vielleicht ja. 3000 Kalorien am Tag, ja klar. Ich meine du verbrauchst durch pures Existieren schon ordentlich was an Kalorien.
Ja, natürlich kommt es aufs Gewicht und sowas an, ja.
Max holt sich bald sowas. Kann ich das anklicken hier im Stream? Ich meine es kommt von Modgiz, dann hoffe ich mal das da. Sowas, das habe ich mir auch schon angeguckt, das hat mir persönlich nicht so zugesagt. Ich habe Socken, ich habe so Socken für einzelne Zehen.
Ich habe so Socken mittlerweile, aber ich glaube Schuhe eher nicht. Ne, also wenn du, sagen wir mal im Durchschnitt 93 Kilo wiegst, wie ich und beim Rennen immer auf die, weil das geht halt sehr aufs Bein, ich merke es ja auch so schon mit gepolsterten Schuhen, auf die Knie und auf Schienbein.
Also es ist deutlich angenehmer, wenn du was gepolstertes drunter hast. Haben deine Zehen viel Spielraum? Ne, eigentlich nicht. Aber es ist auch nicht so, als würde es irgendwo kratzen oder so. Die passen eigentlich, also ich habe 44,5 Größe von denen und das geht eigentlich ziemlich gut.
Erster Arbeitstag am Freitag? Pog. Kannst du sagen, ich bin ein Mordgäber im Wupplo aus Fivehead. Gleich mehr Geld. Only Fivehead, nur Fiveheader sollen mit mir reden hier. Alles, alles, alles ohne Chat-IQ mache ich nicht.
Hast du noch irgendwelche Tipps, um die erste Woche gut zu überstehen? Tja, eigentlich müsste ich gute Tipps haben, weil bei mir ist die erste Woche im neuen Job ja selbst noch nicht lange her. Also, ganz ehrlich, guck, dass du alle Zugänge, Hardware und so dir organisierst. Du wirst eh komplett überfordert sein, was Abkürzungen und eigene Sprechweise angeht.
Also, wenn ich eine Sache gemerkt habe, ich meine, es ist jetzt nicht so, als hätte ich jedes Jahr den Arbeitgeber gewechselt, aber ein paar Mal ist es jetzt schon der Fall gewesen und zum letzten Mal eben am 1. April. Wenn mir eine Sache aufgefallen ist, jedes Unternehmen hat so einen leicht anderen Slang.
Auch wenn, ich nenne es halt einfach mal so, ein leicht anderes Enterprise-Speak. Also, sprich, auch wenn man überall vielleicht ähnliche Aufgabenbereiche hat, ja, irgendwie IT, Linux, sonst was in der Richtung, es reden trotzdem alle anders, es haben alle andere Abkürzungen, es bezeichnen viele gleiche Dinger anders.
Zum Beispiel, eine, ich habe vergessen, wie es heißt, ja, genau. Im alten Unternehmen, wo ich war, da gab es für Störungen und für Services gab es verschiedene Klassifizierungen.
Da gab es dann zum Beispiel sowas wie eine Stufe-1-Störung, das bedeutete, das ist ein sehr wichtiger Service und es sind da auch quasi viele oder besonders wichtige Kunden betroffen, so, das war dann eine Stufe-1-Störung.
Im Unternehmen, wo ich jetzt bin, ist es eine nicht Stufe-1, sondern, das ist das höchste, eine Klasse-3. Das sind so Dinger, wo man sich denkt, okay, jeder labert irgendwas anderes, aber meinen eigentlich alle das gleiche. Da muss man sich erstmal dran gewöhnen.
Und es gibt überall etwas anderen Slang und Business-Speak, so Enterprise-Speak, das macht jedes Unternehmen ein bisschen anders. Zumindest eine Sache, was alle Unternehmen gemein haben ist, und das wirst du wahrscheinlich auch merken, wenn du neu anfängst, alle feiern sich, alle Unternehmen feiern sich übelst.
Das muss einem ein bisschen ins eine Ohr, also man darf sich dadurch nicht zu sehr beeindrucken lassen, das muss einem ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen, ich weiß nicht, Chat, wie seht ihr das? Aus meiner Meinung, meiner Meinung ist dazu, das können die ja alle machen in einem gewissen Rahmen, aber es muss einem schon ein bisschen ins eine Ohr reingehen und ins andere rausgehen.
Weil ich, ich kann mich einfach nicht genug damit identifizieren, dass ich die gleichen Sachen abfeier, wie das, was irgendjemand da erzählt. Ich krieg das, ich krieg das, ich, ich verstehe oftmals, was sie sagen wollen und viele der Aussagen dahinter sind auch gar nicht schlecht, aber du weißt halt eh, es werden immer nur die besten Sachen rausgepickt und erzählt und letztendlich denken, tun alle Unternehmen so, als tun sie der Menschheit was Gutes.
In Wirklichkeit geht's um Kohle machen und so, das ist doch allen klar. Ich find das immer ein bisschen, bisschen blöd, wenn da so, sich so ultra krass selbst gehuldigt wird. Das geht mir bei Stellenanzeigen schon immer auf den Keks. Also meiner Meinung nach, es macht keinen Sinn, irgendwie dann, dann irgendwie zu nerven und blöde Fragen zu stellen oder so, weil die stehen ja da oftmals auch viele Leute dahinter und so. Hat keinen Sinn, ins eine Ohr rein, ins andere Ohr raus, wenn da wieder die Selbsthuldigungsgeschichte kommt.
Triton, moin, dankeschön für den Sub. Brock, 6 Monate. Exzellent, exzellent.
Guckst, dass du weißt, wo was Wichtiges ist. Wann hat die Kantine auf, wichtige Sachen zuerst, logischerweise. Wann macht die Kantine auf, wann macht die Kantine zu, wann macht irgendein Kiosk auf, wann macht irgendein Kiosk zu, Getränkeautomat, wo ist das Ganze, in welchem Stock, in welche Ecke setze ich.
Was dein Büro ist und so ein paar Sachen, wo man wie wohin kommt. Und vielleicht, was für die erste Woche noch ganz gut ist, wenn man versucht so rauszuhören, was so die Dinger sind, die man vielleicht besser nicht machen sollte. Jedes Unternehmen hat da immer so ein bisschen andere Sachen.
Ich meine klar, es gibt die offensichtlichsten Sachen, die jeder weiß. Du solltest nichts klauen, dann wirst du instant rausgeschmissen. Aber das meine ich nicht. Es gibt in manchen Unternehmen eben so ungeschriebene Regeln, die beim anderen vollkommen okay sind.
Nehmen wir mal ein Beispiel. Bei dem einen Unternehmen ist es vollkommen okay, wenn du aus einem Meeting rausgehst, wenn es laut Kalender fertig ist, obwohl die Leute noch am diskutieren sind, ohne dass du was sagst. Du haust einfach ab. Vollkommen okay.
In einem anderen Unternehmen wirst du vielleicht doof angeguckt, warum du einfach abhaust. Und in einem wieder anderen Unternehmen, wenn du sagst, ich muss jetzt weg, ich hab noch ein anderes Parallelmeeting, noch einen anderen Termin, dann sagen sie, ja dann geh doch einfach und spam nicht im Chat rum. Also das ist überall ein bisschen anders und eventuell auch von Gruppe zu Gruppe und Team zu Team alles ein bisschen anders.
Also es gibt überall Dinge, da macht man sich ein bisschen unbeliebt mit. Und wenn man da so die erste Woche mal drauf achtet, man merkt das ja auch bei den anderen, ein bisschen drauf achten ist nicht verkehrt, dann macht man selber halt das nicht.
Und wenn du beispielsweise einen Ausbildungsleiter hast, der eben sehr scharf drauf ist, dass du freitags deinen Ausbildungsbericht vorlegst, ja dann guck halt, dass du dem bis freitags den Ausbildungsbericht vorlegst. Bei mir war es so, bei mir haben sie sich drei Jahre nicht für die Ausbildungsberichte interessiert und dementsprechend, naja.
Chat, was meint ihr, wie viele Ausbildungsberichte hatte ich geschrieben bis zum dritten Jahr oder bis kurz vor meiner Abschlussprüfung? Drei, null, nee es waren weder drei noch null. Ich denke mal, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, was es waren, ich denke mal so 15 oder so 10, 15, irgendwie sowas, ja.
Weil ich hab die ersten paar Wochen das noch relativ gewissenhaft gemacht und dann hat halt meine Faulheit overtaked und dann hab ich ab und zu mal wieder welche gemacht und irgendwann hab ich einfach, so nach dem ersten halben Jahr hab ich einfach gar keine mehr gemacht und dann musste ich, musste ich quasi zu meiner Abschlussprüfung zusammenfaken drei Jahre Abschlussbericht, äh drei Jahre, drei Jahre Ausbildungsnachweiseberichte.
Ich, ich hab da was gebastelt, was automatisch das zusammenbestückelt und die waren richtig schlecht, also ohne Scheiß, meine Ausbildungsberichte waren die schlechtsten, ich glaube, ich glaube, schlechte Ausbildungsberichte kannst du nicht haben. Teilweise ganze Tage gar nichts, was da drin stand. Dann, dann, dann hatte ich so 20, 25 Sachen, die sich immer wiederholt haben und so, richtig mies alles.
Das liest sich eh keiner durch. Verlass dich mal nicht drauf. Wie gesagt, vielleicht hast du einen Ausbildungsbetreuer, der da voll drauf steht und das gerne sich jeden Freitag anguckt, jeden Montag sich vorstellt. Guck, benutze die erste Woche, um so ein bisschen Gefühl für den Laden zu kriegen. Das ist, glaube ich, der beste, der beste Tipp, den man einem geben kann.
Und versuch, sag ich so, versuch einen möglichst netten und guten Eindruck zu machen, ja. Erster Eindruck ist entscheidend, dein Chef und wer auch immer sonst wie Vorstellungsgespräch mit dir hatte, der kennt dich ja zumindest, der hat dich schon mal gesehen, aber viele Leute triffst du da zum ersten Mal und wenn du, wenn du gleich anfängst mit den blöden Sprüchen, was manche machen, was bei uns in der, in dem alten Unternehmen, wo wir auch ab und zu auch ein paar Azubis gekümmert haben, hatten wir wirklich welche.
Die haben halt dann schon in der ersten Woche irgendwelche coolen Sprüche gebracht. Das haben die nicht gemacht, weil sie gedacht haben, irgendwie das wäre ein sonderlich schlauer Spruch. Die wollten halt irgendeinen coolen Spruch machen, weil sie gedacht haben, weil sie nicht besser wussten, was sie sagen sollten. Ja, also da sollte man vielleicht die erste Woche ein bisschen am Riemen reißen.
Wenn man die Leute dann kennt und wenn man die Leute kennt und weiß, wer wie tickt, da kann man das machen. In der ersten Woche ist glaube ich echt das Beste, was man machen kann, ein bisschen das Gefühl für den Laden kriegen, wie da die Dinger laufen und wie so die Leute ticken, ja.
Du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du
du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du
Ich hab letztens ne Abrechnung gesehen, von jemand anderem, der hatte Wochenendeinsatz und Bereitschaft, der hat knapp 1000 Euro am Wochenende verdient, ohne groß was zu machen, das ist wirklich so, wie hat mal aus Spaß einer gesagt, Infinite Money Glitch, aber es ist ja nicht so, als reiß ich mich da drum, die wollen ja, dass ich das mache, aber mal aus Business Sicht,
ja, aus Business Sicht macht es natürlich Sinn, Leute, das ist ja kein, wir verschenken Geld, das hab ich schon oft genug erzählt, solche Sachen sind durchkalkuliert, die überlegen sich, ok, wir haben so und so wichtige, wir haben diese und diese wichtigen Services, wenn diese Services ausfallen, bedeutet das im Durchschnitt einen finanziellen Verlust oder einen finanziellen Schaden von, keine Ahnung,
500.000 Euro pro Stunde ausfallen und das rechnen die dann hoch und sagen sich, ok, wir hoffen ja nicht, dass das passiert, aber wenn wir jemand in Bereitschaft haben und für den Fall der Fälle, dass es doch alle, was weiß ich, 2, 3 Jahre mal ein bisschen ruckelt, ist der da, auch nachts um 3 und der kann das fixen, bis morgens die Börse aufmacht,
Versus, wir verlieren 2, das war zumindest früher bei der Bank, keine Ahnung, wir verlieren irgendwie 2 Tage an der Börse, wo sie handeln können oder sowas, das sind Millionenverluste, Versus, du bezahlst einen Typ ordentlich fürs Nichtstun und irgendjemand hat das kalkuliert und gesagt, hey, es lohnt sich, unsere Leute fürs Nichtstun zu bezahlen,
weil für den seltenen Fall der Fälle, dass wirklich mal was ist, sparen wir so viel Geld, dass sich das wieder lohnt und deswegen werden in so einem Bereich halt Bereitschaftsbereitschaften gemacht, in denen eigentlich nie was passiert, aber nur für den Fall der Fälle lohnt es sich trotzdem.
Was hältst du von dem Lizenzwechsel von Terraform? Ich kann diesen riesen Aufschrei darum nicht wirklich verstehen, Terraform kann weiterhin benutzt werden, das einzige, was du nicht machen kannst, ist quasi mit Terraform ein Konkurrenzprodukt zu Terraform bauen, ja, mir ist klar, dass es ganz streng genommen keine clean Open Source Lizenz im Sinne der Open Software Foundation oder wie die heißen ist,
weil du eben nicht free bist, alles zu machen, was du willst, aber so den riesen Aufschrei und wir forken Terraform und so, ich fühl's noch nicht, wie man so schön sagt. Hast du eigentlich schon mal was mit Redis gemacht? Ja, aber nicht so, dass ich mich damit groß auskennen würde.
Welche Sprache hat kein Debugger? Gibt's bestimmt welche, Brainfuck oder so. Gibt es, also C++ hat welche. Gibt es gescheite C++ Debugger, die keine IDE-Integration sind? Bestimmt, ich mein, C++ ist eines der verbreitesten Sprachen, allerdings auch eines der beschissensten Sprachen. Das heißt aber nicht, dass die Tools schlecht sein müssen.
Seniorenheld, danke für den Sub. Ich glaube, den hab ich gesehen. Ich glaube, den hab ich gesehen. Das hat auf irgendeinem Artikel verlinkt. Ich glaube, ich hab sogar den Artikel, das war ein ziemlich kleiner Blog-Eintrag, nur auf den er verlinkt hat, gell. Relativ kurz und knackig. Ich krieg's aber nicht mehr zusammen.
Wie weit hast du bis zweimal im Monat vor Ort? Ich bin ungefähr einmal die Woche in Frankfurt. Spätestens alle zwei Wochen. Alle eins bis zwei Wochen. Alle zwei Wochen bin ich auf jeden Fall da, weil da ist dienstags immer riesen Meeting-Tag.
Da war ich auch schon. Die sind nice. Die heißen irgendwas Feinkost oder sowas, gell. Die sind nice und zwar, wo wir gerade bei PepoFett in Frankfurt sind. Die sind nice, die haben richtig gute Sandwiches und die haben mega nice Nudelsalat mit Tomaten, mit so getrocknetem Tomaten-Zeug drinnen.
Und die haben auch so Joghurt mit Kirschenzeug und so drin, das ist auch gut. Aber, wobei ist das der? Nee, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment. Doch, doch, ich glaub, das sind die. Wobei ich mir jetzt gar nicht sicher bin, ob ich den nicht verwechsel.
Doch, da kann man oben sitzen, oder? Die haben oben so eine Etage, wo man noch sitzen kann. Ja, da kann man oben sitzen. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es das ist, was ich meine. Egal, genug Frankfurt, PepoFett. Gleiches Bett geht heim, ja.
Boah, das ist schon lange her. 2017 oder so? Ja, die wissen es halt nicht besser.
Da kann ich dir nichts zu sagen.
Ey, du bist nicht zu alt dafür. Wie gesagt, ich war auch, ich hab auch schon eine Ausbildung davor gemacht und hatte kein Studium und sonst was. Ich war zwar noch nicht ganz 28, aber ich war auch schon ein bisschen älter. Also, du bist auch bei weitem nicht der Einzige. Das wirst du auch, falls du eine Ausbildung machst und noch in die Berufsschule geschickt wirst und sowas.
Und du dann da auch wirklich hingehst, was ja nicht wirklich zwingend erforderlich ist, wirst du das auch sehen. Du hast noch mehr, die älter sind.
So, Leute, wir haben es geschafft. Chat geht. Schön, dass ihr dabei gewesen seid. Recht spontane Geschichte heute wieder gewesen und wir haben eigentlich nur zwei Stunden sinnlos rumgeschwätzt, so wie das sein muss. Richtiger WhitePepoHappyStream.
Ab 22 Uhr lief die Hälfte. Vielleicht morgen. Können wir mal gucken. Ab 22, ich seh das, ab 22 Uhr liefen immer die Hälfte der Zuschauer. Okay, ein Drittel der Zuschauer lief instant 22 Uhr. Versteh ich aber. Weil Boomer müde, Boomer schlafen. Denen geht's genauso wie mir. Aber ich geh jetzt pennen, Leute. Wir sehen uns, beziehungsweise nicht ganz richtig. Wir hören uns. Bis denn, macht's gut. See you.